to to linger on the division between
the static and the dynamic so much of
the work in computer vision so many of
the breakthroughs that you've been a
part of
have been in the static world in
looking at static images and then you've
also
worked on starting but it's a much
smaller degree the community is looking
at dynamic and video
at dynamic scenes and then there is
robotic vision
which is dynamic but also where you
actually have a robot in the physical
world interacting based on that vision
which problem is harder
the the the sort of the the trivial
first answers
well of course one image is harder but
so if you look at a deeper question
there
are we um what's the term cutting
ourselves
cutting ourselves at the knees or like
making the problem harder by focusing on
the
images that's a fair question i think
uh sometimes we we can
simplify our problem so much uh
that we essentially lose
part of the juice that could enable us
to solve the problem
and one could reasonably argue that to
some extent this happens when we go from
video to single images
now historically uh you have to consider
the limits of
imposed by the competition capabilities
we had
so if we many of the choices made in the
computer vision community
uh through the 70s 80s 90s
can be understood as
choices which were forced upon us by
the fact that we just didn't have access
to compute
enough compute not enough memory none of
hard drives not
exactly not enough not enough compute
not enough storage
so so think of these choices so one of
the choices is
focusing on single images rather than
video okay
clear questions storage and compute uh
we had to focus on we did we
used to detect edges and throw away the
image right so you have an image
which i say 256 by 256 pixels and
instead of keeping around the
grayscale value what we did was we
detected edges
find the places where the brightness
changes a lot
so now that and now and then throw away
the rest
so this was a major compression device
and the hope was that this makes it
that you can still work with it and the
logic was humans can interpret a line
drawing
and uh and yes and this will save us a
computation so many of the choices were
dictated by that
i think uh today
we are no longer detecting edges right
we
process images with convnets because we
don't need to we don't have that
those computer restrictions anymore now
video is still under studied because
video compute is still quite challenging
if you are
a university researcher i think video
computing is not so challenging if you
are at
google or facebook or amazon still super
challenging i've
just spoke with the vp of engineering
google head of
the youtube search and discovery and
they still struggle doing stuff on
video it's very difficult except doing
except using techniques that are
essentially the techniques you used in
in the 90s
some very basic computer vision
techniques
no that's when you want to do things at
scale so if
you want to operate at the scale of all
the content of youtube it's very
challenging and there's similar issues
in facebook
but as a researcher you you have you
have more
uh you know opportunities you can train
large
you know that works with relatively
large uh video data sets yeah
yes so i think that this is part of the
reason why we have
so emphasize static images i think that
this is changing
and over the next few years i see a lot
more progress happening in
in video so i i have this generic
statement that
to me video recognition feels like 10
years behind
object recognition and you can quantify
that because
you can take some of the challenging
with your data sets and
their performance on action
classification is like say 30
which is kind of what we used to have
around
2009 in object detection you know so
it's like about 10 years behind
and uh whether it'll take 10 years to
catch up is a different question
hopefully it will take less than that
let me ask a similar question i've
already asked but once again so for
dynamic scenes
do you think do you think some kind of
injection
of knowledge basis and reasoning is
required
to help improve like action recognition
like if if if um
if we solve the general action
recognition problem
what do you think the solution would
look like it's another way yeah
so i i completely
agree that knowledge is called for and
that knowledge can be quite
sophisticated
so the way i would say it is that
perception blends into cognition
and cognition brings in issues of memory
and
[Music]
this notion of a schema from psychology
which is
uh let me use the classic example which
is
you go to a restaurant right now the
things that
happen in a certain order you walk in
somebody takes you to a table
a waiter comes gives you a menu
takes the order food arrives eventually
the bill arrives etc etc uh this is a
classic example
of ai from the 1970s
uh it was called there was the term
frames and
scripts and schemas these are all quite
similar ideas
okay and then in the 70s the way uh
the ai of the time dealt with it was by
hand coding this
so they hand coded in this notion of a
script and the various
stages and the actors and so on and so
forth
and use that to interpret for example
language
i mean if there's a description of a of
a story involving
some people eating at a restaurant there
are way all these
inferences you can make because you know
what happens typically at a restaurant
so i think this kind of uh
this kind of knowledge is absolutely
essential so i think that
when we are going to do long-form video
understanding
we are going to need to do this i think
the kinds of technology that we have
right now with
3d convolutions over a couple of seconds
of clip or video
it's very much tailored towards
short-term video understanding
not that long-term understanding
long-term understanding
requires a notion of
this notion of schemas that i talked
about perhaps some notions of
goals intentionality functionality
and so on and so forth now how will we
bring that in
so we could either revert back to the
70s and say okay i'm going to hand code
in
a script or we might
try to learn it so i
tend to believe that we have to find
learning ways of doing this
because i think learning ways glenda
being more robust
and there must be a learning version of
the story because
uh children acquire a lot of this
knowledge
by sort of just observation so
at no moment in a child's life does a
it's possible but i think it's not so
typical that
somebody that a mother coaches a child
through all the stages of what happens
in a restaurant
they just go as a family they they they
go to the restaurant they eat come back
and the child goes through 10 such
experiences and the child has
has got a schema of what happens when
you go to a restaurant
so we somehow need to we need to
provide that capability to our systems
you